[Music]
welcome back good afternoon to our
special edition of the D Armstrong Show
featuring acclaimed actor Danny Glover a
man of many interests including an
interest in healthy living and joining
us is Dr Sanjay they're representing a
company and a philosophy called
youngevity uh youngevity is about doing
the best we can as far as ingesting good
vitamins and minerals
and being able to live as long and
healthy as possible thank you so much
for being with us gentlemen well thank
you thank you now there is some
award-winning research behind youngevity
because many people are being bombarded
with take this take this take that so
why youngevity sure well our founder Dr
Joel Wallock has been researching the
value of nutrition for over 40 years uh
he's written several Publications books
such we believe that the reason why
you're in the situation that you're in
is because you have nutritional
deficiencies that are caused from the
lack of nutrients from the foods that
you're eating so over 40 years he's done
everything from agricultural samples to
um animal autopsies finding out where
the clustering of all of this is created
and therefore has created an entire
program to truly help people by giving
back the nutrients that their bodies
need now Danny I I imagined that they
had to probably pass a threshold for you
to say yes I will join join with you
what made you say I I believe in what
you're doing well the the first thing
that I was introduced I have a
extraordinary business partner relle
Salsbury who lives in Atlanta and the
first the first thing that when she
introduced this product to
me and I heard the name Dr Joel wallet
connected to
it something snapped into my memory
about 15 years ago maybe even longer
than that I listened to a tap called
Dead Doctors Don't Lie I'm familiar with
that I gave that to me and I read I
listen to tape several times in fact I
referenc the tape several times during
that period of time I went out to the to
the vitamin store to try to get the
trace minerals and all the things that
you suggested in in at that because
because in his research and he was a
buried man he was a veterinarian he was
he researched the human body as well and
he was concerned that we had depleted
the soil of vitamins and nutrients and
minerals so if it's not in the soil it's
not in the plant then it's not in us he
studied the pathology of disease so
instead of the medication look in the
cancers and the diabetes and the
Alzheimer's of what the symptom is
what's the root issues and that root is
min it's nutrient deficiencies and
specific mineral deficiencies and the
only way for you to get your minerals is
from the soil and so if the soils are
depleted because they've been uh uh uh
farmed improperly because theyve uh not
tilled because they've been growing the
same thing year after year after year it
depletes those nutrients it doesn't get
into the food if it doesn't get into the
food it doesn't get into you because it
doesn't get into you that starts the
root of your and I know that and he said
something else he said the Egyptian Army
was as strong as it was because of the
fertilization of the Nile Valley M the
Nile Valley the most fertile place in
Egyptian Army was strong that because of
the wheat they ate and everything else
the food that they ate grown in that and
even going back to Bible times I know
that there was uh uh admonitions to not
overarm the land that you should let the
land rest for seven years and I know
that even in our history in the United
States that farmers have gone back and
forth I can't rest the land I need to
make money they're like but if you don't
rest the land then your food is not
going to there's a growing population
there's a growing population I got to
feed that population it forces me to
have to grow the same thing all the time
cu I got to specialize in it and then on
top of that because you want to eat so
much I've got to start processing this
food which further leads those nutrients
and it turns into this huge like kind of
cycle that you can't get out of and the
only way to get out of it is by making
sure that you get those nutrients
consistently back in you and it's really
too bad that for the last 30 or 40 years
everybody's been using the old model of
trying to treat these illnesses and
diseases people have to stop thinking
that obes it and diabetes and cancer and
Alzheimer's is things that they're going
to be at their Mercy you can solve these
things and you solve it nutritionally
wow I know one of the things that he was
uh got in kind of a little trouble but
he was Vindicated later was that
nutrition was linked or a lack of n
nutrition to cystic fibrosis and is is
that he had done the research he had
done all of this amazing research that
showed that wait a second cystic
fibrosis is not a genetic Condition it's
truly because of a selenium deficiency
and he was able to prove that deficiency
in these animal models but I'll tell you
what that doesn't create big money for
big Pharma and so because of that that
research got pulled out no you I'm not
going to publish these papers and you
know what Dr Wallock you don't even know
what you're doing he was the one telling
everybody eat butter he was the one
everyone to telling don't eat gluten
stop eating these grains now today what
do you see you hear all of it wow now
are we going is the nutrients going to
keep you around for a long time I'm
counting on
it all right at least after the break
but you know the one the wonderful thing
is about it is that I I said that first
of all I'd heard the tape years ago and
then when I was introduced to the
product I began to take the product I
wanted to be I wanted to be have my own
narrative I wanted to have my own story
about how the product affected me wow
we're going to give you an opportunity
to meet him later because you're going
to be be talking about the product here
in Columbus but will you do something uh
with me gentlemen uh we're going to go
to a break come back and I would like to
make a healthy snack would you join me
you bet you I love it he'll cook it
we'll be right back with Dr sanj and
Danny Glover and we're going to allow
some audience questions questions when
we come back it's the
[Music]
I